okay well we're going to talk about
support vector machines today which is a
another way of doing classification and
it's a direct approach to the
classification problem
um in in a single line we try and find a
plane that separates the classes in in
feature space
and support vector machines are a very
popular way of classifying and there's a
one reason for it is the name is very
neat you're probably thinking as you
hear the title support vector machine so
the word support is kind of interesting
and machine
uh evokes something much larger and
powerful and we'll talk we'll tell you
where the name comes from as we talk
about the the method
it was actually due to vapnek a applied
mathematician from the former soviet
union who came over to the united states
around 1990
and and developed this the method with
cortez while working at bell labs where
trevor used to work
yes they were at a lab down the road
and
when they first
came and talked about support vector
machines and having this great new idea
i was i scoffed a little bit and i
thought oh yeah another
you know brazen
claim by computer scientists but uh well
turns out it's pretty good
right and you'll see it's a it's a
unique kind of way it's it's it approach
the classification problem in a way
computer scientists would approach it
there's no probability model as such it
really just looks for a hyperplane that
separates the classes in a direct way
so they've been around for about
20 years now and support vector machines
are still
firmly embedded in the in the community
and and considered one of the best ways
of doing classification
so we're going to we're going to tell
you about them um today
the idea with support vector machines as
we said is to to
find the plane that separates the
classes in feature space
and we'll tell you what we mean by that
by a plane and and separation and so on
um
and but the idea is natural you try and
separate the two classes i mean that's
what we want to do when you classify but
you can't you'll see we cannot always do
that
and the the technology
gets creative
in two ways one is that we soften what
we mean by separates and the other is
that we enrich and enlarge a feature
space so that the separation becomes
possible
before we can get into this let's just
talk about what is a hyperplane so i'll
give you some technical definition and
then i'll show you a picture
so a hyperplane is in p dimensions if
you've got p features is a flat affine
subspace of dimension p minus one
well if that didn't help you let's just
look at a little bit deeper
in in general the equation of a
hyperplane
has a form as follows it's a
an equation here's a linear equation
that's equal to zero
okay it's called a
linear a linear function
in two dimensions a hyperplane will be a
line and that's the one i'll demonstrate
in the next slide
and if beta 0 which is called the
intercept if that is zero then the
hyperplane goes through through the
origin otherwise it doesn't
and the vector beta one through beta p
excluding beta0 is called the normal
vector it points in a direction
orthogonal to the surface of the
hyperplane
so let's have a look at the picture and
see what we mean by that so in this
picture the blue
the blue line is the hyperplane
we've got some points in the picture and
we've got there's the origin over here
and we've got this red line which is the
normal to the hyperplane
so it's orthogonal to the surface of the
hyperplane
and the way you understand what's going
on is as follows
for any given point
so for example take this point over here
we can project it onto the normal so
here you see the orthogonal projection
little right angle showing that we
projecting orthogonal
fungally onto this normal over here
right and so we get the distance from
the origin where this point projects
well in this case that the value that
you get
is
1.6 well that's actually the value of
the function yeah
for the points beyond the hyperplane
the value of the function should end up
to be zero
so which points are going to project
onto this normal and have a value zero
well they're going to be all points on
the hyperplane because you can see
there's a right angle there too so if we
project this point it's going to project
over over here
if we project this point it's going to
project over here
and
the value of the function is 0 over here
so all these points
end up having the function value zero
and so they on the hyperplane these
points on the other hand don't
in this example the direction the beta1
and beta2 are given by 0.8 and 0.6
in the bottom corner here those are the
two values for beta1 and beta2 that that
define this this normal
well if you check you'll see that the
sum of squares of beta1 and beta2 adds
up to one
that means that this beta is a unit
vector
and
so the direction vector is a unit vector
and when that's the case there's
something special happens and that is
that
when you evaluate the function the value
that get you get is actually the
distance the euclidean distance of the
point from the hyperplane
now that's not too hard to prove but we
won't do that here but for those of you
who
for those of you who can do a little bit
of
calculus and no bit of geometry see if
you can try and show that it's not that
hard
so this point is 1.6 units from the
hyperplane
this point over here
is -4 units from the hyperplane so
there's a sign in the in the distance
it's one side of the hyperplane that's
going to be negative the other side
positive
all points on this side would end up
having a positive distance or points on
this side a negative distance and of
course all the points on the hyper plane
are a distance zero
so that's a little tutorial on hyper
planes
so with that in place we can now talk of
separating hyper planes
so in these two pictures what we show a
set of points some are colored blue some
have covered a pinky mauve color
okay
and
we've got three lines in in this picture
over here and you'll notice that each of
these three lines separates the blues
from the purples from the moves
this one does
because there's all blue points on one
side all purple points on this side so
does this one and so does the other one
so all three of them separate the two
classes
so in terms of making a classifier in
principle all three of those would do
if we pick one of them
we can say well that's going to define
the classifier it separates the two
classes
anything to this side we classify as
blue anything to this side will classify
as purple
from what we've seen before
we know that on one side of the
hyperplane the function is going to be
positive and on the other side it's
going to be negative
okay
so what we can do is code the colored
points
and those that are
blue say we make them one and those that
are
move we make them minus one
and then we can
we can say that if the y that we've made
y is plus or minus 1 times the value of
the function
is positive
then
we classify
each of the points perfectly because
they're on the right side of the
hyperplane
and the the function itself evaluated as
zero is called the separate in
hyperplane
so
so that
helps us define what we mean by
separating hyperplane if this product is
always positive where we've coded the
points as plus one and minus one
now
it's all very well coming up with a
separate and hyperplane but we've got
many to choose from so if we had to
choose which one would we pick
and so that brings us on to the idea of
the maximal margin classifier
so the idea is the same set of points
the ideas amongst all separating hyper
planes find the one that makes the
biggest margin or biggest gap between
the two classes right and we've
indicated over here there's a hyperplane
in fact this is the optimal one here
found through an algorithm we'll we'll
tell you about
and you can see that the the hyper plane
is exactly equidistant from the closest
blue point and the closest move point
and that makes the biggest gap
so why why is that interesting having
the biggest gap well the idea is simply
that
if you make a big gap on the training
data these are training data hopefully
when you put plop test points down there
you'll also make a big gap on them
that's that's an underlying thought of
course
from a statistics point of view that's
maybe not always going to make sense
because it seems like this is this
overfitting we focus in on a few of the
very closest points but we'll see in in
general it seems to perform very well
so that's the idea of the maximal margin
classifier
now how do you actually do that well
somewhat technical you can set it up as
as a
optimization problem and this is how we
do it so first of all we constrain the
sum of squares of the of the betas to be
one remember these are the betas here
not the beta zero and if the sum of
squares of these are one then the
function evaluates to the distance if
you multiply it by the y i which is
coded as plus one or minus one
this year is the distance of the eighth
point from the current hyperplane
defined by the betas okay now we want to
make
it and and it's it's a sine distance so
if they're all positive it means all the
points on the correct side of the
hyperplane
and if we want to maximize a margin we
want to find that hyperplane for which
these distances are all as big as
possible so we want all of them to be
bigger than some number m and we're
going to maximize that m so we're going
to find the parameters that gives us the
largest m such that for every point they
at least m
units from the hyperplane
okay
so that's a nice
mathematical way of defining the problem
to solve it it actually goes a little
bit beyond the scope of this class so
that's what you see the the the uphill
car logo there that's in the book as
well
the way it's phrased here it's not quite
a convex optimization problem but you
can rephrase it and make it one and and
then you can solve it using
software and there's a function svm in r
for example in the package
with a strange name e1071 and we'll see
when we do the labs that that solves the
separating hyperplane problem
okay so we've
we've seen how to solve the separating
hyperplane problem we got an algorithm
for doing it
and and it's a pretty slick algorithm we
get the maximal margin classifier
well we're going to see
that
that that's not going to be good enough
and in the next section we'll talk about
what we do in cases when you cannot get
a separate in hyperplane and we'll also
talk about what how we deal with noisy
data as well